chaque année le concours miss france est
accompagné du même package par jean
pierre foucault une candidate qui dit
des trucs pas très clair mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait là celle-là mais est bien
sûr une polémique sur les miss en
maillot car quoi qu'on fasse t chaque
année le même refrain pour certains les
miss ne devrait pas porter de deux
pièces et arnaques est que tout est trop
trop trop dénudée pour d'autres au delà
du maillot deux pièces ou du bikini le
sujet et surtout le fait d'exposer des
femmes en maillot de bain une pratique
plus vraiment dans l'air du temps et une
sexualisation de la femme objet que
beaucoup dénoncent c'est un concours
dans les fondamentaux sont sexistes
moi je suis pour l'abolition de ce
concours pourtant cette année encore le
comité miss france a fait le choix de
faire poser les 29 prétendantes de cette
100e édition en maillot alors miss
france les photos en maillot de bain
sont elles dépassées alors doucement et
pourtant mes yeux parce qu'elle dépasse
lui jeunes en mars atteignant alors
personnellement je trouve que oui le
fond bleu effet piscine et l'est
vraiment ringard genre ça parle pas aux
jeunes nous on voudrait intrus peut-être
un peu plus moderne
ouais c'est vrai que mon regard là c'est
vraiment j'ai soutien c'est n'importe
quoi mais ulissi de la crotte
non mais sans succès on va voir quelques
photos même temps vous allez voilà baron
regarder au delà on a mis ce corps c'est
miss côte d'azur qui sont magnifiques
les pôles mon lait peut poser nos
enfants piscine les regarder ça avec des
trucs à côté un modèle mais c'est
honteux les mêmes on en dise 912 week et
des vidéos bien alors c'est pas moderne
mais à vrai dire on s'en fiche un
concours s'élèvera poil bah oui le but
de demi fond
quant à leur maillot de bain son corps
ça ce n'est qu'une heure du conte
on les voit on est satisfait que je sais
pas moi je peux pas entendre des choses
comme ça regardez moi je regarde miss
france pour apprendre la france autorise
les aides très sympa je voudrais
quelqu'un d'intéressant alors on y vient
donc ce ne sera pas de ce côté je vous
savez partie du charme de miss france
ont aussi envie de les voir un peu
dénudée il faut savoir que le concours
miss france c'est un débours de miss les
plus prudes au monde dans doute elle
défile en lingerie donc franchement
dématérialisée moi j'ai vu bien méchant
mais j'ai vu les émois miss danemark la
wii non mais miss danemark mais c'est
une lingerie mais suez opérait en avant
l'origine est nourrie suède
elles font toutes les miss france et
devenir un concours complètement
aseptisés on n'a plus droit de rien dire
ne rien faire on n'a pas lancé mettant
mieux demain c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable oui il m'a dit je vais
attentionné la vielle à roue allait
l'aider malaisie pourquoi mr démago mais
à tanger que je vais pas commencer à
parler que tu me saute dessus moi aussi
c'est rétrograde c'est ce existe des
plus du toit en phase avec notre temps
mais non le rouler
complètement hypocrite à son la wii le
féminisme et y aura un jury sans succès
fait mineur c'est la marque honda beauté
et bat encore une fois on le sait rouler
au maillot de bain on peut très bien les
laisser en maillot de bain mais à côté
arrêter de faire une minute d'une
interview on sait pas ce qu'elles ont
dans la tête on sait maintenant l'idée
de les voir défiler quelque chose je
veux dire quelque chose il ya eu quatre
interventions sur les miss france 4
mauvaise j'aimerais bien en avoir une
bonne franck tapiro non mais ça sera pas
non mais on le sait que j'avais 15 ans
qui travaillent avec vous je le sais
mais non évidemment que non c'est pas
parce que ces photos là c'est sûr notre
plus racé que d'autres peut-être qu'ils
font enlever les femmes en maillot de
l'émission sont maintenant n'oublions
pas que c'est ce salut parti la
tradition on arrête miss france laisse à
fond est vrai qu'en six miss france
existe il faut que ce soit complètement
afin qu'elles son maillot je vois pas où
est le côté sexisme faut qu'on
m'explique
elle est appréciée justement en tant
qu'individu juste pour la rive non ici
on s'est entendus ici et ici on lève la
main pour qu'on la parole si on sait
maintenant on est deux on est sûr m
radio ici c'est la mission mais jugé
uniquement qu'avec les photos en maillot
de bain je serais d'accord mais c'est
pas ça oui les voir pleins d'autres
domaines que je vois pas pour mémoire à
demi masqué en maillot de bain ça c'est
mais oui à la minute
franchement je dis la vérité de minutes
je ne crois pas aux tomates
je te le dis ce que tu veux il a été
condamné à plus d' âneries en nous car
oui oui tu es mon avis je te dis of la
légende vendent pas et je ne crois pas
un instant
non mais où se voit après l'émission et
peut-être conduire ou bien toi tu veux
tu es sûr tu veux parler maintenant
oui alors alors attendez l'intervention
d'isabelle louis cane francs mon idole a
été très intelligent mais en revanche
stéphanie tu confonds le féminin et le
féminisme qui me pardonne moi si c'est
si ringarde moi c'est catherine pourquoi
pas toujours des décolletés
[Applaudissements]
six ans et j'ai pas demandé à ce qu'on a
juste sur des critères physiques et pour
vous répondre
fo quad est alors en tout cas dans les
deux minutes maya l'abeille à tabac me
sondages je suis pas sélectionneur je
peux pas me présenter au concours miss
france et non je m'assume justement et
c'est ça justement être féministe c'est
que je m'assume en tant que femme et je
suis pas baser uniquement sur des
critères physiques et qu'est ce que font
d'autres alors pendant le concours à
part des filets apparaître ont malgré
tout fait des phrases beaucoup trop
longue va vous réfugier dans balances
ton poste dans la mesure où c'est un
concours de beauté
on attend ce moment avec impatience
d'ailleurs dans les miss france vous
êtes trois pics d'audience le premier
c'est lorsque vous avez les questions
réponses des messages adore c'est le
deuxième ce truc c'est le couronnement
est le troisième le défilé en maillot de
bain dassault on attend ça avec
impatience
on va voir les photos des deux jeunes
filles en maillot de bain parce que
histoire de se faire une idée si les
fautes ont été mis aux prises il ya miss
franche comté
parions regardez c'est sarah le coeur et
damien mercereau un de deux très bons
journalistes qu'ils ont fait voilà qui
ont fait cet article regardez miss
franche comté c'est coralie gamblin et
ben ali et bah écoutez je pense qu'elle
devrait prendre des cours de natation
elle est taillée pour elena chca or ça
c'est miss guyane magnifique qui a l'air
sympathique miss guyane
j'aime bien un flacon ben barka j'aime
bien elle est pétillante ya juste eu
peut voir miss ile-de-france et laura
l'art à louhans so we
ouais ouais ouais élancé way regardez le
maillot de languedoc-roussillon plus à
notre style de maillots donc les miss en
maillot
vous êtes pour blue note magali bernard
ça génial et pour rebondir sur ce que
tiffany disais tout à l'heure je trouve
que le fait aujourd'hui de dire que
quelqu'un est sexiste c'est de ne pas
laisser la femme s'est montrée telle
n'allait ces femmes là sont là pour
kiffer en fait mais l'appartement où
elles deviennent plus vif et on doit les
laisser libres de ce qu'elles ont envie
de faire comme je vais prendre des notes
dans ce que vous dites sont là pour me
fait oui d'accord voilà mais à partir du
moment où tu kiffes être là et montrer
leur corps faut les laisser faire c'est
ça être bien vous êtes pour vous
allez les muscles et les maillots c'est
la miss france c'est quoi c'est une
tradition chez nous bah là pour le coup
moi je suis en ce cas je suis assez
d'accord qu'à partir du moment où elles
font un concours d'autres indiquent
elles savent ce qui les attend tout
simplement donc c'est qu'elles sont
d'accord dans un film comme ça donc si
c'est leur choix leur jeu voilà moi je
vous dire je partais un principe et je
te le téléspectateur ce conte et
vendredi je dis tout puissant filtre
j'ai pas peur de prendre des risques
je vais dire un truc qui va peut-être
choquer quoi chacun voit midi à sa porte